Robert Mugabe Zimbabwe is founding
leader is dead
some saw him as a liberator others a
tyrant
so what legacy does he leave and how
will Zimbabwe emerge from his shadow
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program I am
Hashim Alberta robert mugabe was a
divisive figure right up until he died
on Friday at the age of 95 he was hailed
a hero of Zimbabwe independence from
Britain but after turbulent 37 years as
president the military deposed him in
2017 African leaders are paying tribute
to Mugabe as an icon of liberation but
his critics say his thirst for power
left Zimbabwe ruins of the Hameed takes
a look back at Robert Mugabe's life 1965
Rhodesia and IANS mrs. white settlers
declare independence from Britain an
event that defined Robert Mugabe's life
and still holds his country the black
majority resisted racist rule in the
cities and out in the countryside where
vicious bush war raged for years Robert
Mugabe a teacher turned activist emerged
from prison as an articulate leader of
the independence struggle we started the
war in order to get our country and we
haven't got our country they did get
their country at Lancaster House in
London in 1979 and when Zimbabwe
celebrated independence Mugabe the
overwhelming winner of elections was in
power and soon showing rival liberation
fighters what he'd do to keep it
Matabele Island in the early 80s the
opposition crushed thousands killed in
ethnic massacres atrocities that were
barely noticed abroad but there was also
much to admire racial reconciliation
education and health for millions of
Zimbabwean although later the economy
declined and the invasions of white
farms in the year 2000 we're turning
point this time the world did notice it
was a chaotic destructive process but
who GABA said he was correcting an old
injustice and in many ways still
fighting the old colonial power the land
is ours we give it to whom we please
it's not the business of Britain you see
to tell us who to give
nemu not by now opposition was growing
despite torture murder and manipulation
many Zimbabwe seemed ready to throw
Mugabe out they had a new hero
Morgan Chenjerai who said Robert
Mugabe's early achievements will always
be overshadowed by the years of
oppression
d'hui portrayal as the great liberator
oddly portrayed as someone who has
betrayed the liberation that he fought
for I think the letter will prevail the
two rivals ended up in government
together
although Mugabe made sure he kept the
real power and chunky rile later
returned to opposition where he would
eventually die he is a despot he's a
dictator he's a tyrant he's any word you
want to throw at him but he's something
more than that
he's the wrong messenger with the right
message by now his wife Grace 41 years
his junior had emerged as a political
player Mugabe well into his 90s seemed
determined to go on and on in the city's
anger boiled over a new generation
demanded Mugabe go it's time for you to
resign it's time for you to step down in
the end it was the army that pushed him
worried he'd appoint grace as his
successor a former colleague and deadly
rival of Grace's Emerson Moonen GOG WA
took over it was more Palace crude and
revolution although the joy mirrored
death of Zimbabwe's original revolution
37 years earlier will gabby retreated to
his mansion bitter to the last the real
tragedy Robert Mugabe could never bear
the idea of his country enjoying a
second freedom from his ruinous grip
[Music]
let's bring in our gas in Harare Patrick
Chinna Massa a ruling Zanu PF party
member who served as Robert Mugabe's
finance minister in London
Alex Magatha the former chief adviser to
the former Zimbabwean prime minister and
opposition leader Morgan Tsvangirai and
in Johannesburg David Moore professor of
development studies at the University of
Johannesburg welcome to your Patrick the
mixed reactions following the death of
mr. Mugabe from a liberator to a tyrant
does that in a way or another fairly sum
up his legacy well Zimbabwe and the
people's and Bob we are going to be in
deep mourning over the past moon of
comrade ROG Mugabe we have been our
leader and a revolutionary icon which
championed and led the armed struggle
which gave us our freedom our human
rights and our dignity you will be one
of the Great's of Africa alongside
former hemangioma Julius Nyerere
Agostinho Neto Kenneth Kaunda Nelson
Mandela he will be he is a revolutionary
icon not just African icon but also
international he championed the cause of
oppressed people everywhere and he was
very principled he was very strong and
is one of a few leaders in post-colonial
Africa we had taken edge only colonial
masters and rested our land to give it
back to his rightful people he was
infringing in that result okay he left a
huge legacy for empowerment of our
people
in the area of education Zimbabweans are
now read the highest in terms of
literacy rate and also in terms of
skills development this is why you'll
find it in Dublin's all over the world
because of the earth key it seems but
the biggest achievement was giving land
back we will talk more in details about
those issues Alex Morgan Tsvangirai who
was the main opposition leader in
Zimbabwe once said that if we were to
make any assessment about the legacy of
Mugabe between a freedom fighter or
someone who had deserved the right given
to him by his own people that latter
would prevail well I think first of all
you know condolences of course to the
family of former President Mugabe I have
listened to what for my administration
Amasa has said there is no doubt that Mr
Mugabe played an important role in the
liberation of Zimbabwe and had many
important words to say about Africa and
he was indeed an icon in that regard
however as Shangri pointed out at the
time there are also aspects of mr.
Micawber's leadership which were very
disagreeable which were very horrible
and I think that it's important to
understand that even at this particular
point in time while we have to respect
the family of Mr Mugabe it's also
important to be honest and truthful
about the challenges that Zimbabwe has
faced Zimbabwe falada his leadership mr.
chinnough Massa was part of a group of
people in zanu-pf who led the ouster of
President Robert Mugabe in 2017 I don't
think that it is fair to whitewash that
episode of our history if anything the
demise of former President Robert Mugabe
began that November 2017 when they took
power from him to
one constitutional means Patrick I mean
when we go back and look at the
highlights of the legacy of Mugabe many
people would tell you that okay who was
a freedom fighter for the independence
of his own country but those credentials
were completely overshadowed by the
blunders by the mistakes that he made
over many many years in power I don't
agree with that proposition what I think
people should know about Mugabe is that
he was very angry that we had an African
person in opposition since I've been
opposition finance and created by former
colonial masses the British smooth the
West Minister Foundation funded the
creation and establishment of MDC he was
very very angry that is imbalance how
could you see bubbles betray their own
legacy how Buddhism bubbles betrayed
their own country by accepting silver in
order to oppose the land question he was
very angry over that issue so the issue
that she is rest here about the events
of 2017 we are not perfect we all have
our shortcomings but Mugabe shortcomings
fell into insignificance when compared
with his achievements not just in
Zimbabwe but internationally and one
shortcoming that I could earn up to is
that he left the succession issue too
late and as you know because of
advancement in edge the scary things we
are getting out of control and a clique
of individuals surrounded is white in
order to advance their own personal
interests which had nothing to do with
the country's national interests okay
that is what led to the events of 2017
let's go to a more advanced targeting
anti Mugabe it was basically that chain
well now immiscible okay let's go to
David Moore in Johannesburg David it was
quite interesting the reactions we got
from African leaders basically
describing Mr Mugabe as an icon of the
pan-african pro-independence
movement but when it comes to the West
the main sentiment was basically this
was a tyrant who abused his power for
many decades which led or which drove
the country to the brink of collapse
right well statesmen and diplomats
protect each other generally and I think
that's been the case often times if you
speak to diplomats behind closed doors
and off the record they say quite
different things and they certainly have
had in the past but Robert Mugabe has
been able to marshal the ideology of
sovereignty and pan-africanism to put
them on their back feet usually except
of course in 2008 when after the victory
of Morgan Cheng RI in the election at
the end of March forced a runoff
well of course a lot of fake counting as
well but that's not unusual and Mugabe
and his people killed at least the very
least 177 MDC supporters at that time
Sadek and the AU had had enough and
pushed him into a unity government but
he was able to make that work to his
benefit as well which he's always been
able to do he's been very good at
picking out the soft spots in the
opponent's armor and also pitching
various camps in his own party but also
in the international arena especially
during the Cold War at each other and
been able to sneak through those those
those cracks and maintain himself in
power he's very very good at that I
think it's very interesting that in some
contradiction to your former speaker the
people on the streets are actually
indicating I would say a 30/70
centage ratio against and for robert
mugabe and that's that's fairly unique
in these days because people generally
is not like they don't like to speak ill
of the dead but there's already
indications that his real legacy is not
as good as it's been made out to be Alex
with Zimbabwe
turning the chapter of Robert Mugabe do
you see an opening for what could be
fresh political start in the country
well I think that if the events of
November 2017 had not happened and if Mr
Mugabe had passed on while he was in
power perhaps one would be talking of a
new fresh chapter coming up but I think
what we have seen so far is that Mr
Mugabe is political death happened in
November 2017 and contrary to what we
are hearing from my countrymen Mr Tomaso
they have been trying their level best
over the past 12 months 18 months to
distance themselves from the legacy of
Mr Mugabe it's only now that they are
calling him comrade Mugabe because it's
a title that they often use for their
own colleagues and friends in their
meeting newspapers they have been
calling him mr. McCotter
and all sorts of things so it's a bit
hypocritical you know so to speak that
is being uploaded and given all these
accolades
now when for the past 12 18 months they
treated him like a leper
really now in terms of Zimbabwe going
forward I think that clearly the
challenges that were supposed to be
solved in November 2017 have not been
resolved the last election in August in
July 2018 left a lot of hanging
questions and that's why Zimbabwe
continues to suffer serious isolation
serious economic deterioration as has
been said by many people the solutions
to Zimbabwe challenges lie in the
political arena and it is there that
Zimbabweans have to find a solution the
passing on of Mr Mugabe
does not have the same impact that it
had had he passed on during his time in
power mr. Patrick I've listened to you
defending the legacy of Mr Mugabe but a
certain point this is this is my if you
could just bear for a second this is my
question to you mr. chinnough Massa the
2008 elections the Constitution provided
for a two-stage process if a candidate
did not achieve 50% plus one there was
to be rerun they felt that the lady in
the first stage does not make him a
winner of an election I wanted just to
collect nomination at least we are being
critical you should you should just give
some credit source language because in
the second round of the election he said
okay just going back to what we said
about 2008 you should just give some
credit to stronger I who said that I
cannot afford to see more people killed
because of the election and therefore he
decided to stay away from the second
round of the vote but this is this is my
question to you I've listened to you
you're defending the legacy of Robert
Mugabe but there's a universal consensus
that the guqin handi massacres committed
in the Matabeleland was one of the
gravest crimes committed during the
reign of Robert Mugabe still you're
completely in denial about it as you
know the liberation of this country was
brought about by true liberation
movements to liberation nationalist
movements at Independence than one the
majority and went into a coalition with
disciplined but these agreements like
among all revolutionaries take place
misunderstandings takes place and some
of these misunderstandings are spawned
by those who wanted to suggest
organization so that period is
regrettable but in bad ways we'll find
solution amongst ourselves without the
involvement of outsiders okay I just
wanted to highlight here yeah but we
never been mr. Patrick how can you move
it I see your point
how can you move forward if you're not
willing to acknowledge mistakes that
were made crimes that were committed in
the past reconciliation is foremost
about saying we make mistakes the first
to announce the police afresh
racial reconciliation amongst with
former colonial masters that was a very
important decision that he took and he
was always a man of peace a manual
reconciliation and the current president
has already given this matter of googler
wounded to the peace and reconciliation
commission which is superintendent by
for vice-president Mahad so we will find
our solutions without interference okay
leaders we know our problems and it is
very important that Outsiders leave us
alone the problem about Zimbabwe is an
opposition which is funded by the former
colonial masters who caused this
tabulation in this country there was
reference to Latvia time this is exactly
what Robert Mugabe has been saying for
37 years collection but someone don't
know that it won the elections we are
okay I need to include David Moore here
David the factional divide is something
which has been endemic in different
parts of the African continent and we
comes to Zimbabwe we have the D berries
and the Shona is this something which
you think would further continue to
undermine the chances for any political
reconciliation in the future in Zimbabwe
I think it's a bit difficult to hear you
but
I think the way in which the
reconciliation attempts are going ahead
is creating some more divisions in
Matabeleland than one would would would
hope and that could be the way in which
the current regime is is handling some
of these issues I think overall one can
see quite clearly from Patrick Jin
amasses response a very rote zanu-pf
response to some of these issues that
you've raised and I think perhaps Robert
Mugabe's last words that were publicly
announced and in February 21st of this
year on his 95th birthday that sort of
sanctimonious holier than now I've
holier-than-thou I've never done any
wrong discourse of actually blaming
Emerson managua for the deaths in
January of this year when at least 17
people were killed in in the
demonstrations and he said something to
the effect that are you only happy when
you're killing people why is it that
death makes you happy something like
that and that's kind of indicated the
the sensibility that I think Robert
Mugabe has left among people in power
and even people contesting for power
there's this kind of religious
religiosity about it
I think Mugabe really did think that he
could save Serah EPF from falling apart
he thought by playing off factions
against each other but that of course at
one one moment would help him keep in
power but at the same moment and and and
and sort of put things in balance again
but then he would have to put things in
imbalance again in order to keep that
sort of factionalism going but
simultaneously cooled down a bit and
that in the end has probably destroyed
zanu-pf I don't think we even now with
with more and Goguen have a cohesive
security for us we don't have economic
issues solved so Mugabe ISM in a sense
has remained
even though it's sometimes the new
regime has said is trying to reverse the
difficulties this was going to be my
question to Alex very briefly Alex
there were helps that the post Mugabe
legacy with Emerson Managua empower with
see dramatic change when it comes to
reforms of the political laws and the
economy people seem to be really
disillusioned now more than ever
well when mr. Managua came in in 2017
there were a lot of people who were very
hopeful they were naive but they were
very hopeful that he will change they
did not understand that mr. Managua and
the people that were taken over had been
an integral part of mr. Micawber's
regime as you know old habits die hard
they have continued with the legacy of
Mr Mugabe for sure and that is why you
hear mr. chinnough Massa who is a senior
member of zanu-pf continuing with the
rhetoric that accuses the opposition of
being Western funded as if they
themselves during the liberation
struggle did not get funding from all
over the world including Western
countries that is not to excuse anything
but it is simply to say that people
shall be seen for who they are they
support themselves they look after
themselves
they are free to express themselves and
it's a political right this idea of
excluding people on the basis of their
political affiliation it means what is
gotten is in bad way and many other
Africa countries down and so it is
important for than we have to really
take a more mature thank you honest and
sober approach to politics change
recognizes everybody else
unfortunately general will will have to
leave it there thank you very much
indeed part of China masa and Expo Gaza
and David Moore we really appreciate
your contribution to the program looking
forward to talking to you in the near
future and thank you too for watching
you can see the program again any time
by visiting our website aljazeera.com
for further discussion go to our
Facebook page
that's facebook.com forward slash AJ
inside story you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is
add AJ inside story from me hash about
about the whole team here in Doha bye
for now
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
you